hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another special edition DVD
review and may I remind you that there's
no reason
oh yeah you should be moaning cuz today
we've got doomsday machine oh this is
about as pretentious sexist and
downright pointless a movie you could
ever see in the sci-fi genre it's corny
it's weird it's downright savage at
times it made you buy the DVD so there
must be something good about it
let's take a look at doomsday machine
first of all you gotta love that score
right just put the conductor in front of
a coffee maker and call it a soundtrack
[Music]
we don't cut to a super secret lab
apparently it's so secret that they
protect it with one entire guard you're
all over Obama when he squashes a fly
and yet super kitty gets a free pass so
that's right all of the problems in this
movie can be traced back to one simple
source so in this maximum security
resort the spies come across a scientist
going to work and you'll never believe
how she kills her
[Music]
so just to clarify the most dangerous
weapons in this movie so far our cats
and pig tails
there can only be one organization to
pull this off
the littlest petshop assassins so she
meets up with our others by friend and
we see what their plan is to breakout
Robby the Robot danger Will Robinson
I've been in here so long I like men not
only am I the kid with that lock all we
can do is form with the red phone don't
work so much Chinese people
now speaking English for some reason
discover some sort of well doomsday
machine and figure out there's no way to
stop it this is my favorite by the way
the lady Spy takes off her fake black
hair to reveal black hair wait why did
you need that this brings us to a space
station called Astro where a press
conference is going on talking about the
astronauts latest travel into space
gentlemen it is t minus 120 so we'll
have to make this very brief Colonel
white is trip to Venus
I understand it's over 160 million miles
away since 1965 our satellites space
stations our lunar landing and base
established there several years ago all
these efforts have helped prepare us for
the payoff of Phase one putting man on
Venus attention countdown is resumed I
know I swear
it makes my speeches on purpose - 120
why just to not take the long way to get
to a planet and instead of hopping
straight across to it well dr. Haynes
contact yeah could you have held this
meeting but for a million things we're
going on he can't get awarded how long
will the journey take barring unusual
circumstances planned explorations will
be gone two years well what do you
consider unusual circumstances anything
we're not prepared for so in other words
unusual circumstances equals to unusual
circumstances like that includes me
gentlemen that's it this press
conference in history no the president
of Astaroth two minutes ago a nuclear
bomb was dropped in the city and see how
I only scheduled 10 seconds for this
meeting that's all I have to tell you
remember what I said especially the part
about breathing
report to security headquarters for
reclassification
Khrushchev went up with miniskirts this
is 1975 even if you kept up with your
comic books you don't know what China
has been fooling around with so the
astronauts are escorted in their
security Ford wagon and put on their
finest ice cream man uniforms to go into
space but there's just one little hiccup
you are to replace 3 of your crew
three other up women now I've heard
everything
what are we gonna beat the inside of the
shit pink or put turns on the windows
next they'll be wanting to vote Colonel
this is ridiculous it's absolutely
insane your minds
yeah I mean what kind of men would
possibly want women on their two-year
absence away from humanity
you know guys a little clam baking your
sausage factory might not be such a bad
idea
what about the emotional stability of a
mixed crew in deep space for over two
years
colonel we're quite not haven't you seen
the dictionary in 1975 women emotionally
unstable dishwashing Babymakers I'd like
to see the passage of time prove me
wrong this is dr. Mary Ann Turner light
surgeon microbiologist lieutenant
Carlson the computer is summit tech and
meteorology major Brodsky co-pilot
revival we call their Scary Spice I
haven't said anything yet doc what can
you say Colonel it's a presidential
order
there must be worse things colonel
ladies
I don't believe you know must be a
practical so they get suited up to go
roles a mafia stock footage and finally
shoot up into space leprechaun pissing
the earth today what's with all the
greed I don't know what about dr. Perry
but the doctor is having trouble
breathing
so one of the women decides to give him
some oxygen despite the fact that they
only have one minute before the
thrusters kick in mr. Bronski get into
your seat we fire in less than a minute
[Music]
hey Jeff Bronski oh I don't think she's
in much danger
you guys did dress more like you're
being shot out of a cannon as opposed to
going into space so I think she's well
protected her heat exchanges and
preservation gifts data time sequence
our unity war program come in yes what a
man open that for you if you need help
moving furniture or telling you how a
football game works we'll be happy to
help you with that - Thank You Frankie
Danny get your high-heeled spacesuit
back to that lazy boy Sharon push for
climb damn it push your climb so they
make the jump and they're on their way
to Venus but something still doesn't
feel right
they sure pushed us out of earth all
that fast I got a feeling that something
more than a war involved yeah like no
how do you realistically top war the
women of course show a classic case of
helmet hair as they find it's not always
easy to get along with their male
counterparts and with only three
personnel modules on the ship we should
get quite familiar with the routine what
is it
sophisticated Americans suffering from
false modesty in Russia we are more
mature look
in Soviet Russia jump cars jump you
putting females together with the male
animal I trades like this what are we
supposed to do for the next two years
breed lows Pentagon computers are pretty
sharp something has three women
supposing China did destroy the world
there'd be nothing left crews to come
back to so
yeah they have a suspicion that the
world might be doomed and that they
might be the only ones left to
repopulate the species come on Doc your
space happy you were reading the pulse
again doomsday get in
[Music]
I mean you guys aren't taking him
seriously are you those chopstick
jockeys couldn't come off on the planet
buster enjoy your shower love your
homemade water this looks like a job for
some serious booty call would you care
to join me on a tour of the hip see what
makes it tick t-minus five seconds to
gettin it on
let's cut out the games huh you know
what's ahead of us we're all gonna be
cozy together for a nice long time now
why don't you relax enjoy it okay
we're watching a porno I mean think
about it the plot is it's the end of the
world there's only a few men and women
left on this ship and they're forced to
give in to their animal urges yeah
we rented a porno Dan in light of that I
have no choice but to list the top ten
porno titles that this movie should have
had number 10 in space nobody can hear
you fuck number 9
Star Wars number 8 Lotito Leto number 7
voyage of the starship booby prize
number 6 the Dhamma
- matrix number five ET the extra
titillating number Paul hi banger number
three the tight stuff number two babe
Runner and the number one porno title
that this movie should have had is
baseball's why Paul
[Applause]
so will the women look for something to
watch everybody socks with one of the
astronauts puts together what's going on
Oh mess was unnecessary I mean bringing
you women along stargazer panicked and
thought the world was going to end
didn't he forget a few people like you
and me could do a rerun on Adam a name
like that a woman could do the same job
as a look colonel
we're only doing what we were ordered to
do and if it doesn't suit you well I'm
very sorry no without your glasses
you're a very pretty doctor another cock
block seems to get in the way
it's just the earth blowing up yeah it's
like it's the end of the world or
something my god they did it it's
happening here what you got down maniacs
you put me at the greatest position I've
ever been in my life thank you thank you
[Music]
oh shut up and make us a sandwich told
you they were unstable so the earth
explodes or cuts to a flaming orange as
the crew tries to figure out who to do I
mean what to do next
[Music]
I think I got the space madness don't
make me use this one stick closer I'm
warning ya come on Kurt get a hold of
yourself
we all want to live you seem very calm
my years of training what made you
become an astronaut you asked because I
have a woman in my country women follow
the same professions as men as his
movies constantly proven over and over
and over if that'll never catch on it's
oxd wash up I was proud to be the only
woman in a class with six men Oh
I miss being a woman yes because a woman
with a brain clearly isn't a woman it's
just a man without a penis so they're
forced to try and find a new route but
they have to think of it fast because
even more problems keep popping up we
can't afford four months we've got to
get there in less than two the Earth's
explosion has tripled the radiation out
there and it's non-directional we just
can't seal it out it's mostly soft stuff
alphas and betas the gamma concentration
isn't critical yes I know but four
months exposure to it'll mean just one
thing
sterilization a few could by stripping
the ship dropping the booster shell
I know it sounds ridiculous to say that
the weight of a few people could affect
the safety of a 50-ton ship but I've
checked and rechecked it on the computer
and there's no other answer yes that
does sound silly preposterous even but I
trust this movie's scientific
understanding I mean anyone who
decorates the ship to look like the
inside of a skittles bag clearly know is
about space travel and we don't need
those women pressing up these butch
collars something on the James T cock
finds he just can't keep his thrusters
to himself anymore
your vibrations ever stop you know it
has to be sooner or later she fights him
off which doesn't make him to him thanks
: what are you trying to do take your
hands off
[Music]
mother spend the next two months locked
below
so let's decided that the ship can only
carry three people to their final
destination while the rest have to stay
behind and be Trimble child so they're
gonna let the computer side who's the
most logical to continue forward hardly
enough this gets the people acting a
little crazy started this trip I had a
whole world to choose now there's just
me huh
you and me huh go ahead she forgot about
the whole punching thing what's the
answer
hey you're out of order captain but they
then find out that they weren't chosen
to be kept alive which causes mr.
Dickens Bates to go crazy let's roleplay
it's the end of the world we have to
repopulate the human race you slam
yourself right into the air shaft button
hmm funny how they don't get sucked out
and they just hover they're like oh I
don't know they were poorly hung on
wires but hey this is a movie that
dresses the female astronauts like the
Powerpuff Girls so again I can't deny
this movie's scientific understanding
[Music]
two down two more to go there has to be
some other convenient way to acts of the
other unneeded characters never got
myself system check up short there's a
misalignment in the booth to connect
well it turns out there's a power
shortage on the boosters which means
somebody has to go out and fix it this
looks like a job for the expendables
part three oh no it's not the coolest
action start small-time never getting
hurt it's just the expendable people be
expected but you know what that's kind
of cool if you're 80 years old suffer a
blow to the head and don't like
entertainment but they come across some
sort of space station funny they never
noticed that before and the two of them
go inside
[Music]
could you move a little faster
little faster please
[Music]
oh my god you're gonna show us every
step they take in the process of giving
that computer working aren't you oh
they're not even showing the process
they're just keeping the camera at this
angle and they just look at the screen
and I'm not kidding this shot of them
just looking at a TV screen with nothing
going on at all eight minutes long folks
hey oh my god this movie was just bad
before but now we suddenly worked our
way into mannose territory what the hell
are you doing just get something done oh
my god really you're doing this did the
editor just commit suicide movie but
finally after eight minutes okay
something does finally happen they get
some audio we are the collective mind of
this world your craft now warbles okay
be it enough for you to know that during
the span of our evolution our
civilization has witnessed the birth and
death of world
on hold your time is short you may not
enter our world we have witnessed the
self-destructive powers of the Green
Planet in caller trust an advanced
civilization if they came until the
difference between green and blue oh
wait the Leprechaun fizz yeah I guess
that makes sense you have destroyed your
place in the universe
[Music]
wine last of man listened a bit we will
calculate your journey will continue
something very brave and very great
awake you beyond the rim of the universe
at now last command your journey will
begin looking at a magic I pictured go
something
Wow hey it is a magic guy and suddenly
seeing the most beautiful words I've
ever seen in my entire life the end so
humanity can't see this advanced
civilization that can't tell dream from
blue but hey on the plus side something
Goods waiting for him
yay for them sort of a weak-ass ending
for a weak-ass idea isn't it
this movie is sexist racist has no idea
what good sci-fi writing is and the idea
comes out of a porno that the cinema
snob would review it's just dumb as hell
but to be fair it's kind of funny if you
like dumb ass movies well then this one
is certainly up there on the dumb totem
pole
if you crave camp like nobody's business
then you might find this to be your
sci-fi monolith it's corny it's lame
it's filled with enough stupid scenes to
get a lot of laughs out of people so if
that sounds up your alley give it a
watch I'm the Nostalgia Critic after
you'll excuse me I'm gonna find a woman
to wash my socks
[Music]
you
I miss being a woman